at hospitals in the capital Center and
the port city of hadida a daily battle
to save stunted children
child malnutrition here is among the
highest in the world doctors are
struggling to provide therapeutic food
for now but it's not just children who
are hungry their parents are also facing
tough times
two-thirds of yemenis need humanitarian
assistance eight years since the start
of the war the economy has declined
government employees are not paid a
nation of more than 30 million is
getting poorer and hungrier
the UN emergency response in Yemen is
the largest in the world but as the
money Runs Out many fear people may die
of hunger the most uh immediate needs
now is
our funding you know availability of
funding is an issue in Yemen
there are a lot of critical sectors that
are treated foreclosure suspension and
this will need millions of people will
not see age that that is much needed
across the country
in the meantime the International
Community is yet to convince the warning
factions to end the conflict recently a
healthy delegation met Saudi officials
in Riyadh to agree on a permanent
ceasefire and a political solution
but Weeks Later the houthis who are
backed by Iran and control Sana held a
military parade its leaders insist a
deal will only happen when foreign
troops pull out of Yemen and Saudi
Arabia commits billions of dollars in
compensation
the internationally recognized
government in the South blames the
houthis who took over the capital in
2014 for Yemen's troubles
for now Yemen remains divided a
secessionist movement is threatening to
break away in the South while the
saudi-backed government is desperate to
expand its influence beyond the married
and other provinces Al Jazeera
well joining us on set now is Yemen's
prime minister main Abdul Malik who's
representing the internationally
recognized government there good to have
you with us so first of all there's a
huge scale of need isn't there in Yemen
right now a lot of humanitarian
suffering
it's severely underfunded right do you
feel let down by the International
Community
yes it's the results of eight years of
of the conflict it's accumulated
uh we saw No Lack of funding it goes
down from approximately 3 billion a year
in 2018 barely now uh one billion it
started to decrease
before the Russian war and in now the
problem is more severe
many of those programs will cut or shut
down in Yemen and that's why we've been
told by some U.N agencies they will cut
funding to the hospital's fuel Wars
sanitation education many different
programs what will that mean for the
Emily people we have idbs now we have
eight years of four even with the last
one year of two since April
2022 still economic or raging with the
militias so now it will affect all the
private sector supply chain so we have
millions of idbs matter for example more
than 2 million and we have in
West all the places and those people
will pay it's always the people that pay
the price they pay the price there is no
accommodation for them no education idb
comes more than 180 camp in one govern
rate like married despite all other
govern rates and also different Governor
rate they are not prepared with the
infrastructure like
and even in the hottie control area
so you lost jobs agriculture
production uh shrinking the GDB
purchasing power this is all accumulated
and the other dimension is the private
sector resilience we will consume that
the prices Yemen is importing 90 of the
wheat Imports fifty percent is from
Russia and Ukraine we absorbed the shock
last year but now also uh the other
choices yeah and also the prices will
bring inflation to the basic Commodities
and for the main foreign
there's an informal cease fire in place
now
is there any hope that this is going to
lead to a resolution of the conflict
anytime soon
it helps to prevent bloodsheds there is
continuous some small clashes but it's
not the same before the the truce
and also still there is an attempt and
attacks and terrorist attacks against
our oil exports but uh it prevent the
war from escalation and there is a new
uh efforts now from the Saudis it's
truthful we hope that this new efforts
can lead to establish a new framework
for the political process all right
let's uh hope that there'll be peace
soon for the people and enter their
suffering thank you so much for coming
in and talking to us thank you